привет и приветствую всех, это
активный гостевой поток вывода 28.1, это
14 октября 2022 года.
сегодня мы собираемся услышать и
обсудить переосмысление рациональности
Джованни Ролла, так что Джованни
большое спасибо за участие, очень
жду этой презентации и
обсуждения, так что вперед  Спасибо,
спасибо, тогда было приятно
получить ваше приглашение пару
месяцев назад, и я рад быть здесь,
чтобы иметь возможность обсудить мою
работу.
Я избавлю вас от вашего запроса.
Наше предложение. Я представляю
это.  документ, который я написал пару лет назад,
и когда мы говорили за кулисами, у
меня есть я несколько раз менял свое мнение,
и я собираюсь прояснить это
во время презентации, так как я
опубликовал этот документ, но это
приятно  тем не менее, у меня есть
возможность представить это видео здесь и
поделиться им со всем миром, поэтому я очень
счастлив,
поэтому мы будем говорить о
переосмыслении рациональности, и это
маршрут.  Я думал
представить вам, поэтому сначала я буду
говорить о рациональности и
бессодержательном познании, а затем представлю
свою точку зрения, которую я назвал радикально
неактивной рациональностью и безопасностью.
из возражений
первое состоит в том, что то,
что я здесь присутствую, является истинным
либералом в том смысле, что чрезмерно либерально оно
охватывает слишком многое, а второе
возражение, которое, как мне кажется,
может вас больше всего заинтересовать, заключается в том,
совместимо ли оно по эффекту  с прогностическим
процессом в нашем прогностическом кодировании, который
, конечно, находится в помещении,
рядом с двумя автомобилями в центре, чтобы
сделать активное влияние,
так
что
вот, извините,
мои первоначальные мысли по этому поводу таковы,
что традиционно очень
православный  иметь представление о рациональности,
э-э, предполагает, насколько я знаю,
это как предположение, действительно, что
рациональность должна в своих рассуждениях,
что для inst  Я считаю, что B в
действии a являются рациональными тогда и только тогда, когда
существует рассуждение, которое поддерживает
Bure, поэтому, и, конечно, это просто не
какое-либо рассуждение, вопрос рассуждения
должен быть получен с определенными определенными
формальными критериями, такими как классическая
логика или вероятностное рассуждение или
эвристики, поэтому верящие и действующие
рационально в соответствии с этим традиционным
фильмом
требуют соответствия определенным формальным стандартам,
и это, как я уже сказал, кажется мне в
значительной степени предположением о том, что
значит быть рациональным в определении
рациональности с точки зрения рассуждений,
поэтому, если рациональность требует рассуждений
и  если рассуждение включает в себя
оценку убеждений по отношению к определенным формальным
эталонам, то рациональность подразумевает
содержание для познания,
где содержание, как я понимаю, минимально
имеет условия точности,
способные быть
правильными или неправильными, или в или в более
весомом понятии, являющемся истинным или ложным,
поэтому  Идея здесь в том, что рациональность
обязательно включает в себя содержание она включает в себя
убеждения  рассуждения и сравнение или
извините
, что обновляю прямо сейчас
одно обновление программного обеспечения. Мне жаль, что
в моем окне появилось всплывающее окно, так
что это было бы, я думаю, стандартным
взглядом на рациональность,
и
если это так, то рациональность обязательно
включает  Это хорошо согласуется
с классическим когнитивизмом или
когнитивизмом в целом,
который заключается в том, что комбинация
обязательно включает в себя репрезентативное
содержание, по крайней мере, для некоторых
когнитивистов, конечно, это может включать
также
концептуальное содержание, но, по
крайней мере, репрезентативное содержание, которое имеет
условия точности,
но этот классический взгляд не так хорош,
он не обеспечивает такого хорошего соответствия
радикально неактивному и воплощенному
познанию,
которое я здесь имею в виду, не
конкретно о радикализме и активизме
Гудвина Мэна в последних книгах, но я
думаю, что он также бросает вызов другим  взгляды
, которые не преподносятся как радикальные и
активные, но, конечно, они имеют некоторые
общие черты с радикальными и активными.
мы могли бы назвать их радикально воплощенными
взглядами на познание, такими как
взгляды, представленные Иезекиилем
Пауэллом, или
сенсорная модель жизни Бермана, у вас также есть
разновидность инактивизма Галлахера в его
книге 2017 года, а также я имею в виду точку
зрения Тони Кимеро в его  Книга 2009 года по
экологической психологии и динамическим
системам, у всех у них есть общие черты,
и вот я здесь. Я знаю, что это очень
противоречиво, но я рассматриваю эти
взгляды как радикально воплощенные взгляды на
познание, и я особенно
сосредоточен на радикальных и активных взглядах на
кулинарию.
все они говорят, что не распознавание является
репрезентативно содержательным, что в
некотором смысле означает, что мы можем думать о базовых
бессодержательных формах познания
или о бессодержательном уровне базового уровня
узнавания,
которое возникает в результате активного
исследования своего окружения и выходит за
рамки радикального и активизма посредством  что мы имеем в
виду
это может быть эта идея может быть
обналичена с точки зрения освоения сенсомоторных
взаимодействий вопрос знания
- как знание того, как взаимодействовать со своим
окружением, вместо того, чтобы знать, что
вещи вокруг вас такие-то и такие-то, так что
это очень ясно, что, например, Пауло и его
коллеги, и Кимеро делают
в своих книгах, радикал и активизм
имеют определенную тенденцию к искажению  Сенсорные
модельные взаимодействия Сенсорные модельные схемы И
т. д.,
но недавние разработки, я думаю,
включили это, так что это
использование сути этой идеи,
так что, если мы объединим радикальные воплощенные
взгляды на размышления или радикальные и активизм
и классическое топливо на  Рациональность,
которую мы имеем, - это то, что Энгл
описал следующим образом.
Активизм - это точка зрения, согласно которой
познание основано на молитве.
рациональное понимание
посредством идей мелопентина
Хайдеггера, согласно которому отношение
к миру может быть только одноукорененным в
п  Практика бездействия в действии и
практике стажера опосредуется
через тело, поэтому здесь подразумевается,
что в отличие от действия и практики
рациональность на самом деле
не является чем-то, что находится не на очень
базовом уровне комбинации, так
что это то, что произошло, когда мы
Освободите место для базового уровня познания,
укорененного в деятельности и на практике, и
отделите его от верхних уровней
комбинации, которые обычно являются
местом удачной классики рациональности,
поэтому идея в сумме состоит в том, что
спорное познание или базовое
познание возникает посредством чувственного восприятия.  двигательные
занятия не рациональны,
поэтому сенсорные современные занятия, какими бы
добродетелями они ни были, не могут
быть оценены с точки зрения
рациональности, только содержание для познания
сочетание высокого уровня может быть рациональным
определением, которое выражается,
например, в убеждениях, а недавно
и хорошо это что-то  что
я не затронул в документе, но это
было моей неявной мотивацией  Относиться к
этому предмету
как к тому, кто исходит из
философии разума, - это идея мифа
данной, по крайней мере, его версии, как
мне казалось в то время, и меня
правильно убедил рецензент не
касаться этой темы.  это было очень
запутанно в моем первоначальном изложении,
но мне кажется, что если мы отделим
базовое распознавание от рациональной мысли
и действия и не укажем в сторону
колодца, то нет пересечения
между этими двумя уровнями, то кажется, что
радикальный и активизм и  э-э, подобные
взгляды были бы связаны с мифом
о данной непопулярности со стороны Селлерса и
модерации Макдауэллом как с проблемой для
властных областей моего разума,
так что кажется, что это
[Музыка
] философски интересная проблема,
но это не то, что  ну, на
переднем плане статьи моей
неявной мотивацией было объяснить,
как мы можем объединить бессодержательный или
базовый уровень познания посредством сенсорных
современных взаимодействий с отношением  На самом деле, если
вы не можете, кажется, что есть какая-
то данность, которая
не полностью объясняется в нашей
картине ума, так что это то, что я
хотел, я все еще хочу попытаться исследовать
эту интуицию более четко, но я еще не
сделал  я не
касался этого,
но я думаю, что есть что-то в
направлении того, почему то, что я покажу
сегодня, я думаю, что это способ выщипнуть
это обвинение в
приверженности мифу о данности,
так как мы можем переосмыслить рациональность, я
имею в виду  Я думаю, что для того, чтобы избежать этой
проблемы и избежать идеи, что у нас есть
два уровня, полностью отделенных
друг от друга, где один Высший
является локусом классической рациональности, а то, что
еще ниже этого, не рационально. Я
думаю, что идея состоит в том, чтобы отвергнуть
рациональность.  должно быть определено, или оно
обязательно влечет за собой рассуждения
, не нужно все еще понимать, но
тогда задача становится предложить
положительное
предложение о том, что такое рациональность, если не
рассуждения, и вот Сьюзен Х.  urley в
статье, что мои знания - единственные,
которые касаются
этой темы, и я думаю, что она
также была обеспокоена мифом о
данном, кстати, в то время, и он -
длинная цитата отсюда.
может
возникнуть из сложной системы
централизованных иерархических отношений
торможения, облегчения и координации
между различными горизонтальными слоями, каждый
из которых представляет собой динамичную и
ориентированную на окружающую среду рациональность, переосмысленную в
горизонтальных или модульных терминах. Я не
знаю, должна ли она использовать эту
терминологию, но  во всяком случае, именно так она
решила выразить это устойчиво
связано с окружающей средой оно не
зависит только от внутренних процедур, которые являются
посредниками между входом и выходом, таких как
содержание либо для организма в
целом, либо для вертикально ограниченного
центрального когнитивного модуля, а
зависит от  сложные отношения между
выделенным миром, включающие слои, которые
контролируют и реагируют на определенные
аспекты n  естественной и социальной среды
и нейронной сети и уменьшить
их обратную связь от их ответов. Насколько
мне известно, это самый ранний случай, когда
кто-то работает над неактивным
подходом,
который, очевидно,
чаще ассоциируется с работой
авано, который также является активистом, но
в подходе, отличном от радикального и
активизма, и вот самый ранний
и, насколько мне известно, до того, как я написал эту
статью, это то, что самое
ясное предложение рациональности, переосмысленное
в местных терминах, но это
не то, что набрало обороты
после ее публикации в  мои знания на
самом деле я мало что видел с тех пор,
и, подытоживая, идея состоит в том, что мы
должны изменить объяснительный Фокус,
который является рациональностью, не
рассматривается исключительно как Содержание, включающее
способность в этом предложении, оно находится
или Мир, вовлеченный в увеличенные миры.
и является ли он радикально воплощенным, это
зависит от телесной морфологии и действия
и от того, как организм расположен и
действует  s в этой среде идея
будет минимально мертва, так что это то, что я называю
радикально неактивной рациональностью,
в очень
расплывчатом определении, что азиат
действует рационально в той мере, в какой человек
поддерживает умелое взаимодействие
с окружающей средой, координируя свои
когнитивные способности  в зависимости от
окружающих условий ограничений
и твердых станций, и, конечно, это
иногда требует адаптации к
непредвиденным обстоятельствам,
основная интуиция такова,
и интересно сравнить эту
идею радикальной и активной рациональности
с другой идеей Сьюзан Херли
в тексте 2003 года.  она говорит о
причинах для действия, что она утверждает,
что причины для действия могут быть
связаны с контекстом, когда она возражает против
ограничения общности Гарета Эванса,
и это защита идеи
островов практической рациональности,
поэтому она по-прежнему рассматривает рациональность как
нечто, что связано
рассуждать здесь, но такого рода
рассуждения ограничены  d в практическом
контексте, так что это очень прогрессивная
точка зрения по сравнению с традиционной
точкой зрения, о которой я говорил в начале,
но все же более консервативная, чем та, которую
я пытаюсь развить здесь,
так что еще одна вещь, которая, я думаю, должна быть
в авангарде этого  Предложение
состоит в том, что рациональность подразумевает свободу действий и
автономию, потому что что-то или только
что-то, что делает организм, можно
назвать рациональным правильным,
поэтому можно использовать эти идеи из
лагеря автономий и активистов и
из теории того, как игроки относятся к
автономным системам, таким как  Roomba
не может быть рациональным, потому что он не
агент, он не является автором своего
поведения, он разработан внешними
агентами для работы определенным образом, поэтому,
строго говоря, это не нация, поэтому
я бы провел черту, где
хорошо  вы не можете, нет смысла
приписывать рациональность Roomba,
например,
и
для этого
я использую понятия автономности и
адаптивности DiPaolo и других, у вас
есть  Кроме того, недавняя книга изображает
четырехсенсорную модель жизни и ту знаменитую
статью из чаши от 2005 года, где он
говорит об адаптивности,
чтобы установить свои очень общие ограничения
на то, что значит быть русским,
поэтому автономные системы
воспринимаются как ненадежные сети.
ненадежная сеть процессов, потому что
организация и физические границы
создаются самой системой
система постоянно поддерживает свои собственные
условия жизнеспособности, что
известно как осмысление, когда
система исследует условия
окружающей среды, которые
благоприятны для ее самоподдержания и
избегает тех, которые наносят ему ущерб,
поэтому я понимаю, что это
то самое общее, что они
эмоционально ограничивают рациональное существо,
что оно должно быть автономной системой,
и самое интересное здесь то,
что концепция адаптивности, которую Пауло, но
в-четвертых, заключается в том, что способность
организма улучшать свои условия
самопроизводства посредством  h внутренние
структурные изменения,
так что это включает в себя мониторинг и
регулирование внутренних изменений,
чтобы выбрать наилучший доступный образ
действий, я думаю, что это еще одна
интересная концепция для
включения этой идеи радикально
неактивного понятия рациональности, которое
не обязательно стремится к
рассуждениям и содержанию,
поэтому деятельность реализуется за счет
использования ситуативных способностей, которые
способствуют изменениям внутри организма в
соответствии с ограничениями и субстанциями окружающей среды,
что означает, что насколько хорошо организм
адаптируется, чтобы умело справляться
с окружающей средой, является мерой  или
указание на его рациональность, чем
более рациональным является организм, тем более
он приспособлен к взаимодействию с
окружающей средой, и мы предусмотрели
обстоятельства,
и тем самым организм
усиливает непрерывный обмен между собой
и окружающей средой,
который имеет решающее значение для его выживания и
это очень
натурализированный способ мышления о
рациональности  это в основном способность
усиливать изменения для выживания,
это общая идея здесь,
поэтому, как я сказал ранее, что касается рассуждений, которые
я хочу,
я не хочу совершать рациональность
обязательно с рассуждениями, и это
то, что касается радикально неактивной рациональности
, но я  я не хочу исключать
рассуждение как предыдущую рациональную
комбинацию, поэтому я говорю, что
оно не определяется рассуждениями, но это
не значит, что оно не исключает
рассуждения. Я думаю, что рассуждение следует рассматривать
как особый или специфический способ рационального действия.
тот, который является исключительным в наших
знаниях для людей,
но это не определяющая черта
рациональности,
поэтому для этого я, чтобы объяснить
эту идею, я вспоминаю, как хуту и ​​Сатурн
в промежутке между статьей в самой последней
книге Утани они объясняют
Появление высокой узнаваемости идея состоит в том,
что способность использовать контент для
познания в конечном итоге зависит от
социальной культурной интеграции
там, где полное познание контента возникло
из соц.  культурного взаимодействия, так что,
когда человек принимает участие в социально-
культурных практиках,
он принимает более древние когнитивные
способности для работы с символами, и,
делая это, он,
конечно, в ходе длительного процесса инкультурации
становится способным участвовать в
символической координации, которая не является
внутренней.  представление специфично, потому
что оно общедоступно, оно не является мысленным
представлением в традиционном смысле,
но обладает чертами символического
познания без приверженности к
внутреннему представлению или мысленным
представлениям,
поэтому рациональным действием в его самом общем
смысле является идея о том, что умелое
поведение  организм находится в состоянии,
это умелое поведение организма
в окружающей среде, оно зависит от
координации воплощенных способностей,
тогда как рассуждение, если все идет
хорошо, разумеется, понимается как содержание
рациональности для моего конкретного способа
рациональности рассуждение есть умелое
поведение  организм в
социокультурной среде  окружающая
среда, которая, конечно, является более специфическим аспектом нашей среды, и она зависит
от координации такого
культурного или содержания, включающего способности,
которые являются более поздними в человеческой
филогенетической шкале,
так что это самая большая
идея, это  я думаю,
ну, предположительная часть, и
вот возражения, о которых я хотел поговорить,
первое, что это очень либеральный
взгляд, это очень,
ну, это хорошо, он охватывает слишком много,
можно было бы сказать, потому что, если рациональное действие
сводится к координации
когнитивных способностей, тогда рациональность является
чем-то постепенным, поскольку организм может
быть более или менее опытным в своих
взаимодействиях с окружающей средой,
и отказ идет в соответствии с
радикально неактивной рациональностью, многие
организмы достигают и поддерживают
адаптивное поведение в нише с
разным уровнем успеха, к которому я стремлюсь.
э-э, хорошо, кто-то может воспеть рациональные
и активные радикальные и активные
рациональности либералу, и это  одно
возражение, которое я слышал лично,
и я так упорно держал его, потому что я думаю
, что это очень хороший способ
выразить это, даже гвозди рациональны в
этом представлении, и я должен сказать,
что я готов купить  бумажник,
ну, да, он более либерален, чем
традиционные взгляды, конечно, так и
должно быть, но я не думаю, что
это проблема сама по себе, что я думаю
, положительная часть здесь заключается в том, что он
сохраняет разницу в степени, в которой
люди  намного более рациональны, чем другие
животные, просто потому, что мы способны
выполнять широкий спектр действий в
самых разнообразных динамических обстоятельствах
, которые намного превосходят любые другие
известные нам животные,
поэтому вернемся к примеру с
этим гвоздем.  выполнять несколько сложных
действий может перемещаться из одной точки в
другую может искать пищу и
убежище и так далее но у
них критический ограниченный набор способностей
если окружить этот гвоздь
например югом он обречен на гибель от
возражение и люди, с другой
стороны, они гораздо более адаптивны и
способны динамично справляться со многими
непредвиденными обстоятельствами, так что
мой ответ на это возражение таков:
да,
ну, это очень либерально, но это
не проблема, проблема была бы, если бы
это  это если бы у него было место для
разницы в степени между тем, как животные
справляются со своей средой
, и это другое объектное
возражение, которое, я думаю, может быть,
хотя то, что интересует вас больше всего, тогда
вы знаете, это 12-прогностическая обработка
кажется, подразумевает выводы и содержание на
всем пути,
но сначала я должен предупредить вас
и зрителей, что
в то время, когда я писал это, эта статья
была гораздо более оптимистичной в отношении этой
возможности объединения активизма и
предиктивного кодирования или предиктивной
обработки и, э-э,  Я думаю, что здесь есть
важные моменты, но есть
недавняя статья Олу, Эвана Томпсона
и Рэнди Бира, где они
дают критическую оценку  е.
попытки объединить в основном
принцип свободной энергии и
хм
неактивные и
автобиографические теории, так что теперь я в
основном убежден аргументами, но я
думаю, что здесь есть некоторые интересные
точки сравнения, тем не менее,
так что прогностический процесс в нашем прогностическом
коде и э-э на самом деле  время, когда я писал,
и по сей день все еще в моде
в когнитивных науках. Я думаю, вы можете
сказать, что сладости стали
одной из основных парадигм,
поэтому интересно посмотреть, хорошо ли это
согласуется с тем, что я  Я говорю о том,
и в этих зрителях, которых вы знаете,
конкуренция понимается как
процесс минимизации ошибок, который происходит в
двунаправленных узких иерархиях,
поэтому у
вас есть генерация внутренних
моделей активности нижних слоев,
которые предвосхищают отдаленные причины
зловещих стимулов, которые являются  нисходящий
процесс и минимизация
несоответствия между предсказанием и
текущим сигналом стимула за счет
заполнения априорных значений, которые  является
основой процесса,
так что здесь, конечно, активный вывод,
который понимается, например, в
неформальных, вы знаете, формальных терминах
Кларка, что организм перемещает свои
сенсоры способами, которые равнозначны активному поиску в
нашем поколении, производя сенсорные
следствия, которые они скорее  их
мозг ожидает, что
это один из способов понимания активного
влияния на очень формальные термины, но я
думаю, что он выполняет свою работу,
поэтому мозг делает вывод об ожидаемом
источнике полученных стимулов, если
кажется, что есть
проблема с тем, что я  говоря о
том, что его голосование о прогностической
обработке, которая использует
предвзятость продукта и право вывода, говорит,
например, что процесс
перцепционистов отделим от
рационального более широкого предвзятого процесса
размножения и контекстных нисходящих
эффектов, я чувствовал, что каждый промежуточный
уровень  обработка этого привлекла мое
внимание тем, что Кларк тоже
все время говорит о рациональности,
но это  Выводная
рациональность
и всепроникающая аргументация
влиятельного лица, по-видимому, подразумевают непроницаемое содержание,
а затем прогностическая обработка
кажется несовместимой с радикально неактивной
рациональностью.
- геморрой и чтение
прогнозной обработки,
которая использует, например, один первый шаг,
будет использовать дефляционный смысл
прогноза, который понимается как эпизод в
короткой статье 2013 года, но четвертый,
где значения двух или более переменных
ковариируются или имеют надежное значение, поэтому
значение 1 позволяет наблюдателю сделать вывод
о значении другого, и здесь
вывод происходит на
уровне наблюдения, а не на одной дальней
переменной, которая делает вывод о значении
другой, поэтому идея будет заключаться в том, что я думаю,
что содержание находится в глазах
смотрящий человек, который интерпретирует,
как выбор цензуры, который мы помещаем,
приближается к внутренним предсказаниям,
понимаемым здесь в т.  В инфляционном смысле это можно
описать в выводных и предвзятых
терминах, так что вот как я вижу, например,
идею о 4 000 в статье Бруно, название
которой, если я не ошибаюсь,
похоже на то, что мозг не
является ученым, и аргумент находится в  это
общее направление,
которое мы проецируем, как
ученые истолковывают активность мозга как
характеристику самого мозга, как если бы
он предсказывал и делал выводы об этом более
надежном или более весомом смысле,
поэтому я пытаюсь сказать здесь, что
активный вывод, тогда я использую двойное  и
скажите двойной, забыл название этого на
английском, извините,
это не буквальное значение
вывода здесь в соответствии с радикально
неактивной
рациональностью заключается в том, что невооруженный для
эффективности соориентированного поведения
агент должен действовать определенным образом,
чтобы его  его или ее состояния
осуществляются более эффективно и с меньшими затратами,
это не означает более спорного
утверждения, что сами генеративные модели
отображают и выполняют
прогнозные выводы.  Это очень
дефляционное прочтение прогностической
обработки, чтобы обеспечить эту
комбинацию радикальной и активной
рациональностью,
и вот начало статьи
2018 года
по модели, из которой не следует, что
организм имеет внутреннюю
репрезентативную модель своей ниши в том смысле,
что он  это модель, что это
когнитивная работа, если хотите, вместо этого
организм - это модель, которая представляет собой причинно-следственные
и статистические закономерности, отражающие
некоторую окружающую среду, отражающую некоторый
фенотип, который является моделью
, и
это относится к тому, что недавно
мы с коллегой уведомили
говорили об идее о том, как организмы
порождают мир в соответствии с
активизмом, который представляет собой идею о том, что организм
и окружающая среда исторически
исторически называются детерминированными, поэтому
на генетическом уровне потока это
можно объяснить через идею построения ниши,
идею, что когда-то
организм активен в окружающей среде, он
способствует изменениям, которые, если они
достаточно стабильны,  Они могут быть унаследованы
потомками, и эти изменения обеспечивают новые
эволюционные давления прессы
, которые направляют их эволюционный путь.
Подобная идея также была исследована в
другом описании, на этот раз относящемся к
конструкции ниши
и экологической психологии,
поэтому мой ответ на это возражение таков.
что действовать рационально означает
достичь умелого взаимодействия с
окружающей средой посредством предсказания
и ее минимизации. Я готов
принять эту характеристику, но
рациональные и более широкие предвзятые процессы
не должны подразумевать содержание для познания, если
мы,
если мы понимаем, что во Флэше
бессмысленное предсказание и их минимизация
включают в себя выбор входных данных и
координацию взаимодействий в
манерах участия в Мире, что является
главным требованием радикальной и
активной личности, поэтому я думаю, что в той
степени, что прогностическая обработка не
является врагом, скорее,  чем
ложь этой идеи, а не
прибытия, но с  у нас есть другие
проблемы совместимости, которые
я не затронул здесь, но это
все, о чем я подумал на сегодня, спасибо,
круто, спасибо, большое,
хорошо,
круто, очень интересно
для тех, кто смотрит в прямом эфире, пожалуйста, не
стесняйтесь  пишите любые вопросы, я
соберу свои заметки и давайте начнем
дискуссию,
хорошо,
сначала просто еще раз спасибо за
разговор,
как насчет небольшого контекста о том, как вы
пришли к тому, чтобы задавать эти вопросы в
своей нынешней должности, и как
развивались ваши интересы в этой области, потому что
есть  так много интересных идей, и я
просто хотел узнать больше о том, как вы
пришли к этому кадрированию и отточили свою
точку зрения,
хорошо, спасибо, это хороший
вопрос, потому что не часто вы
можете исследовать этот фон,
это важно, так что я был в то время, когда я
думаю, я писал свою докторскую диссертацию,
это было, может быть, в 2007 году или что-то в этом роде, и
я отстаивал идею о том, что
рациональность должна быть чем-то, что в
конечном итоге связано с миром.  в есть
тенденция хорошо думать даже среди как
я сказал, как я показал вам среди э-э в
периоды воплощения с людьми уверенными, что
это должен быть по существу мир,
включающий такие действия и практику
и т.д.
и восприятие, конечно, но рациональность
остается  что-то вроде натурализуемого
понятия, что-то, что нельзя
свести к уровню а, это
нельзя уменьшить,
как восприятие, которое можно было бы
объяснить определенным динамическим взаимодействием и т. д. и
т. д.,
поэтому в то время я думал, что хорошо
возможно, это
проблема колена, потому что
в других
других контекстах подразумевается, что
каким бы ни было восприятие, если оно не
сформулировано таким образом, чтобы обеспечить
определенное соответствие с профессиональной
комбинацией, тогда восприятие является данностью,
и это миф данного
Измерения  в начале и я думал,
что ну может быть это что-
то вроде мифа о
данной работе здесь над активным
познанием но это не я так думаю  это
не фатально, потому что мы не можем, в принципе,
утверждать, что вместо
истолкования ступенчатого восприятия и
других базовых форм комбинаций,
включающих Концепции и тому подобное, возможно, мы
могли бы рассуждать
с другой стороны, пытаясь
уменьшить рациональность до более ненатурализированного
уровня
э-э-э.
так что это была мотивация, и это было
очень, это был долгий процесс обзора, и я
считаю, что моя первая первая
версия статьи зритель был очень я
думаю, что они были полностью правы я,
в конце концов, поддержал предложение, но он
был очень, э-э,
они  были очень непреклонны в том, чтобы принять эту
роль, и я думаю, что это было к лучшему,
потому что это другая литература,
это другая, э-э, много ссылок,
которые обычно не связаны с
активизмом и распознаванием тела, и было
очень трудно просто поставить  в
тех же терминах, чтобы продвигать свои аргументы,
так что это то, что я вычеркнул,
и я не слишком много думал об
этой системе, но я думаю, что это то, что я
хотел бы  вернуться к этому, и, может быть,
даже, возможно, кто-то сделал
это за последние несколько лет, я не знаю, я
могу вспомнить, но
эта связь между активизмом,
мифом о даре и тем, что
кажется, кажется очень
очевидной.  так что, я думаю, что-то, что
мы могли бы, мы должны, я имею в виду, иметь возможность
исследовать, но нет того, что
было на переднем плане статьи,
но у меня была идея поговорить о
рациональности во всех смыслах
и в то же время  время я много читал
о том, что я
назвал его с философской
точки зрения, конечно, я не
очень хорошо разбираюсь в технических
деталях и формальностях подхода,
но меня интересовали
философские последствия там, и я
хорошо подумал  может здесь есть с чем
сравнивать, потому что, как показывают цитаты Кларка,
можно говорить о рациональности все время
, и это то, что я
хотел развить, но не в когнитивистском взгляде,
а не в радикально воплощенном фильме, поэтому
это фон
потрясающий, спасибо, не могли бы вы
описать, что такое миф о
данности, в каком контексте возник этот
миф, и куда мы идем после
поднятия мифа о данности,
потому что я видел это как концепцию, которая  вы
вплели, так о чем это было,
хорошо, так что середина дает это, что
хорошо, есть несколько возможных данностей, в
зависимости от вашего вкуса
моей философии, но наиболее классически в предыдущих
областях разума возьмите
содержание восприятия, которое будет дано  молитва
рационально таким образом, что у нас есть определенные
входные данные, которые только что получены
умом, и ум интерпретирует их так, что
продавцы разные продавцы известны тем,
что описали эту проблему
как проблему не только увеличения
топлива ума, но и  для рационалистов,
но, с другой стороны, рациональное
обычно принимается как рациональная интуиция как
данность, что означает, что существует какой-
то некоторый уровень познания, который не
артикулируется, что это  дан или, как некоторые
люди говорят о воспитании, дан,
но в некотором смысле есть этот уровень
познания, который дан, и разум должен
его интерпретировать, но если он дан
таким образом, у него нет точки соприкосновения, нет
пересечения между чем бы то ни было.
Что бы разум ни делал, и этот базовый
уровень доминирования, поэтому моя идея состоит в том, чтобы
избежать обвинений в
приверженности мифу о данности, но, опять же,
это не то, что явно выражено
в нативистской литературе, но это
то, что кажется  можно
развить в
я имею в виду, э-э, в такого рода сравнении, но
это не это не из
неясного там, а
один из способов их решения для
Гивенов сказать, что перцептивное содержание
уже концептуально по своей природе, что,
например, как Джо Макдауэлл  имеет в
виду, что чем больше вы знаете о
восприятии, тем шутка идет с
субтитрами, вы и интерпретируете мир так,
как вы, но
я думаю, что так или иначе
это демистифицирует вы знаете рациональность
и верхние слои комбинации пытаются и
пытаются думать о них, э-э, в меньшем,
э-э, содержании для анализа,
не фиксируя их, так что это, строго
говоря, с уровнем содержания, который
отделен от базовых уровней
комбинации, это один из способов, которым я думаю об
этом, и  рациональность, по-видимому, является
одной из ключевых концепций для этого, потому
что все это обычно считается чем-то
исключительно человеческим и чем-то, что
связано с рассуждениями, и если это
так, то рациональность не может влиять на действие,
и если, конечно, действие
бессодержательно по своей природе.  Итак, если рациональность
— это смысл, по существу содержательный, а
реакция, по существу, не ограничена для
бессодержательного, тогда вы можете не иметь
этого,
э-э, этого, э-э, пересечения
между двумя областями, и это
то, чего я хотел избежать, но, как я уже
говорил вам, стало так трудно
достаточно ясно и в общих чертах выразить это мнение в том,
что по рекомендации нашего рецензента
я вычеркиваю это и
до сих пор думаю об этом.  но ничего,
я не разработал надлежащую
линию аргументации, которая имеет дело с этим
более четко, чем я могу сделать, как я только что сделал
в очень общих
чертах хорошо, некоторые слова, которые вы связали
с рациональностью, были адаптивность,
а также мастерство, так что вы видите
как связь между рациональностью и
пригодностью
как биологической функцией, да, да,
ладно,
я думаю, что это внутренняя
связь, на самом деле я думаю, что это,
наверное, наиболее
[Музыка]
эм,
очевидное следствие рационального действия
в особом масштабе и когда  мы говорим
о том, является ли рациональность
чертой определенных видов или
индивидуумов. Я думаю, что приспособленность является одной
из ключевых концепций здесь, чтобы думать об этом
как о результате этого
рационального действия,
поэтому, хотя я не говорю, что я не
поместите это в эти вопросы в газете, я
думаю, что можно думать так,
как вы знаете, не рассматривайте это
как возражение думать о
рациональности, но опять же, это очень либерально,
и я не хочу  o принять это
последствие также и для каждого живого
организма таким образом, если он еще не
стал инстинктивным, чтобы он каким-то образом
адаптировался к окружающей среде, поэтому я
готов видеть, что это может включать минимальный
уровень рациональности  Имея дело с
врагом, изменяющимся окружением,
ну, и это цена
очень
либерального прогрессивного представления о
рациональности, это следствие
этого, я полагаю,
поэтому вы сказали, что фитнес является
следствием рационального поведения,
есть ли другие последствия или  как мы
распознаем рациональность извне,
кроме как просто сказать хорошо, что муравьиная
колония процветает настолько, насколько
она рациональна, она адаптивна и
проявляет себя, и все это,
гм, это такая
концепция дефляционной рациональности, что все существующие
вещи, люди и  в противном случае просто
описываются им, или есть какие-то
результаты, которые мы можем использовать, чтобы отделить,
например, рациональное или
иррациональное поведение от просто
последствий, отраженных su  Выживание и
Фитнес
хорошо, я должен был очень
тщательно подумать об этом, потому что я не
хочу упрощать эту концепцию таким образом,
что все является IPS на самом деле или
рациональным по факту, что это
живое, это действующие отношения, но я
думаю, что в конкретных случаях можно
было бы идентифицировать нацию, что я
равен людям,
хм, самодостаточности в этой нише, так что
на индивидуальном уровне, в частности,
хорошо, это одно из решающих определенных
действий, которые могут классифицировать
иррациональные до такой степени, что они
наносят ущерб выживанию,
но на уровне видов
труднее рассуждать таким образом, потому
что идентифицировать такое поведение или
последствия, но я думаю, что для того,
чтобы не упрощать идею
рационального и хорошо говорить обо всем, что есть
жизнь - это факторизованный, вам нужно будет
определить такие конкретные действия
, которые наносят
ущерб одному выживанию,
поэтому в случае с муравьиной колонией я
не знаю, может быть
приветствие захватчиков было
бы таким поведением, которое нанесло
бы ущерб
выживанию как таковому,
я не знаю, я не знаю, так ли это, э-э,
это один из невозможных способов думать
об этом, я должен был мыслить более ясно,
но
мой  осторожно,
очень интересно, и вы внесли
в этот ответ и в
презентацию несколько
вложенных шкал времени, как Eco Evo
Devo, с более биологической
точки зрения, глядя на то, как
построение ниши преодолевает разрыв между
более медленными филогенетическими процессами и более
быстрыми процессами развития,
эм, так  как это
встроенное и многомасштабное соображение
связано с концепцией содержания,
например, будет ли содержимое
локализовано в одном теле, или будет ли содержимое
распределено между сущностями, или
рациональность распределена между сущностями,
как бы мы даже определили
место рациональности и что  также как бы
вызывает гм горизонтальную и модульную
концепцию из цитаты, которую вы
предоставили, так как мы определяем существенные
пространственно-временные масштабы и системы, представляющие
интерес,
о, ах, я не знаю, я не знаю, могу ли я
ответить на это полностью, но мне кажется,
что на уровне, если мы говорим
о содержании, например, содержание как
точность  условия для символических
мыслей, я думаю, к счастью, мы должны
сказать, что это не локализовано в
одном человеке, оно общедоступно,
поэтому вы можете сказать, что
одним из следствий этого является то, что
можно думать о различных
моделях рассуждений, которые есть
на информационных
сайтах.  в разное время и т. д., и вы можете
видеть, что они разработали
различные правила для информации о Контенте на разных уровнях,
и я думаю, что это
правдоподобно, если сказать, что
контент локализован, что
э-э, как вы можете сказать, что он разделяет количество, которое
вы знаете о специфике
просто ради рациональности, я думаю, что
можно
[музыку]
идентифицировать в конкретном поведении,
если это соответствует этому, э-э,
такому описанию э-э-э,
опытного, опытного взаимодействия и
адаптивного поведения.  взаимодействие между организмом
и его окружающей средой, его ниша, поэтому,
вероятно,
мы могли бы дать здесь разные ответы в
качестве рациональности и содержания.
количество других, и это
то, что есть в моей философии
, по крайней мере, с 60-х годов
мои философы
отстаивали идею о том, что содержание внешне
индивидуализировано,
и я думаю, что это одно
из видео  например, Хиллари Патнэм
и Тайлер Бердж и другие утверждают, что
ментальное содержание индивидуализируется на
уровне сообщества или на уровне общества, но
вместе с тем, с другой стороны, они думают, что
рациональность в принципе может быть
индивидуализирована в конкретном поведении, но
это будет зависеть от целей индивидуума
и  ниша, которую он занимает, и
т. д. и т. д.
Здесь, конечно, есть фактические переменные,
которые также могут быть важны
для определения
поведения.  как рационально или нет,
хорошо,
спасибо,
ну, одна фраза, которая действительно
запомнилась мне, была типа «знаю, как не знать», что,
возможно, является базовым моментом в вашей работе
и фокусом на этом действии, поэтому я просто
хотел
услышать о том, как действие и практика, как
вы переплетались  их здесь сегодня, как эти
термины адресованы
и как сегодня обстоят дела по-другому
с трактовкой действия и практики и
ноу-хау, не знаю, что сказать в
helmholtzee в дни или даже в древних
или в традициях Мирового Знания
Итак, ладно, круто, так что идея  Я думаю,
что это тенденция, э-э, это
тенденция очень современной философии,
но на
первую волну когнитивистики оказало большое влияние представление
о восприятии как
о способности категоризировать окружающую среду
и предложить дискретное представление о восприятии.  описание
аспектов окружающей среды, например
, понимание того,
что я знаю, что чашка находится слева от меня, -
это вопрос знания того, что есть
вещь, которая ищет такие свойства для
мой левый, и это своего рода э-э знаете,
что-то вроде пропозиционального отношения
к миру, так что
я думаю, что
интересная вещь об активизме и
экологической психологии, и в той
степени, в которой они напоминают американский
прагматизм с начала
столетие должно думать о
восприятии не как о
категоризации этих великих свойств
в мире, а как о раскрытии
возможностей для действия,
и это то, что, если бы мы
объяснили это в терминах эпидемии,
таких как знание, мы бы  Не
говоря уже о том, что я знаю, что
кривая находится слева от меня, но знаю, как
взять чашку и делать с ней все, что захочу
, если я хочу выпить чашку
кофе или использовать ее как чашку кофе.
пресс-папье у него будут другие
молчаливые свойства, и это то,
что,
хотя это было, я думаю,
очень, я думаю, что активизм, экологическая
психология и другие воплощенные взгляды на
познание были в значительной степени
успешно изменены.  Подводя это обсуждение к этому
моменту, я думаю, что в более
традиционных когнитивных науках у вас все еще
есть идея о том, что
организмы организмы воспринимаются путем
описания того, как окружающая среда,
это то, что, я думаю,
более традиционные прочтения
предсказательной обработки проясняют.
как в идее, что вы делаете вывод
об источнике стимулов, а не
в, и нет, и это не я имею в виду, что
это легче поддается идее,
что мозг или когнитивная
система знает,
что мир  так и так
окружающая среда так и так вместо того, чтобы
сказать, что система повестки дня знает,
как взаимодействовать с миром, и я считаю,
что точка зрения,
которую активисты и экологические
психологи пытаются сделать, заключается в том,
чтобы также работать над прогнозированием
кодирование и принцип свободной энергии и
т. д., чтобы показать, что эти понятия, эти
фреймворки могут быть минимальной идеей, что
система kubernetes знает, как
задействовать, она знает, как заинтересовать  ge в
окружающей среде таким образом, что его не
нужно читать на борту резюме,
что система Kindle делает вывод,
что мир таков, поэтому я думаю, что это
один из способов объяснения, но также и
философский, если у вас есть большой
в начале  последние несколько
десятилетий шла гигантская дискуссия о
том, можно ли свести ни одно Облако к
тому, чтобы знать это, и опять же, у вас есть
фон этого и другого
как независимого понятия от того, что вы знаете
, и можно ли
свести одно к другому и так далее  так что
я думаю, что это не останавливается на достигнутом, вы не можете,
э-э, даже если я могу заявить о
восприятии некоторых других, зная, как
они все еще являются фоновым вопросом
о том, можно ли рассматривать ноу-хау как
и все, что в
любом случае это то, что  Я также
работаю в последнее время,
там есть что сказать, это
такая интересная идея, особенно с
лингвистической коммуникацией, это
немного похоже на палец и луну и
говорить о луне, но палец - это
только  где он находится, и мы говорим не
об указателе, мы говорим
об отсылке,
и поэтому
использовать социокогнитивную форму общения
в культурном языке
или в письменном академическом дискурсе, чтобы вглядываться
в это или переосмысливать это и
видеть даже то, что кажется  быть похожим на
Вершину знать это
и все еще видеть это как знать, как
я думаю, вопрос в том,
как мы читаем документы
да, конечно, да, я думаю, что это э-
э-э, это да, значения, которые, кажется,
могут быть  очень большая проблема, потому что, если
мы попытаемся относиться к этим негативным
способностям, как вы упомянули, как к
ноу-хау,
кажется, что мы все еще упускаем что-то,
например, в общении, а
с другой стороны, я думаю, и это моя
интуиция, но я думаю  что мы могли бы в
принципе говорить о
том,
что понимание того, что вы только что сказали, и
попытка ответить на это зависит от
знания того, как вести себя лингвистически,
но я думаю, что даже это движение
по отношению к когнитивистам высокого уровня,
которое сделало меня  это вопрос ноу-хау, он по-
прежнему упускает что-то из того, что
я делаю, я имею в виду, что лично
я доволен этим, я думаю, что на каком-то
уровне мы должны сказать, что
это еще один подход, который необходим
здесь, чтобы объяснить, как мы  общаться,
например, в
очень адекватном, чтобы не сказать, что это
не предполагает и сейчас, но дело не только в
том, что я думаю, что нужно как минимум больше, чем
практические знания,
но, может быть, ключ здесь в том, чтобы думать о
практических знаниях как о базовых и
необходимых для других видов  других других
видов знаний, которые необходимы
для участия в такого рода обмене,
может быть, может быть, может быть, это один уровень,
я уверен, что
об этом нужно сказать больше, чтобы дать более
информативный ответ, но это на уровне
по крайней мере, моя текущая позиция такова, что
ни как не обеспечивает основу нашего
взаимодействия с миром и с
другими, но в какой-то момент мы
должны быть в состоянии развить другие виды
понимания, чтобы объяснить очень
объяснить сложные виды  обмены, которые мы
имеем в нашей повседневной жизни,
такие как чтение статей, как вы сказали,
я согласен, я думаю, что
формирование знания в качестве основы, а затем
восстановление ноу-хау - это вызов, и
это также вызов, чтобы начать с
основных когнитивных процессов, поскольку они
разыгрываются без дома и  собрать эти
части ноу-хау в знание, опять же,
это не обязательно даже простая
задача, но мы скорее столкнемся
с проблемой сборки символических
пропозициональных декларативных вербальных и
т. д. когнитивных процессов из более
лиминального
экологического когнитивного подхода
или попытаемся восстановить экологическое
из тьюринговского  машина в некотором смысле, так что
кажется, что
вы говорите в поддержку
обоснования экологических правдоподобных базовых когнитивных
процессов, а затем работаете над
сборкой небоскреба
да да да полностью да я думаю, что это
хорошо
оба
эти оба подхода
трудно собрать  как вы сказали, чтобы предоставить
такое объяснение либо
внизу слева, либо сверху вниз, но я  я,
конечно, больше склоняюсь к веб-
подходу, я думаю, что это также по другой
причине, кажется, что отправная точка
кажется биологическим описанием того, как мы
взаимодействуем с миром, а
наоборот, это кажется намного
сложнее  Чтобы объяснить, э-э, как мы приходим
к этим, э-э, биологическим вопросам, таким
как морфология нашего тела и тому подобное, кажется,
что мы должны сначала объяснить это,
а затем мы переходим к другим
вопросам, на которые также трудно
ответить, но в самом  по крайней мере, я думаю
,
что подход «снизу вверх» является более
интегративным в некотором роде, так как шансы
, что он, кажется,
больше в нашу пользу в том смысле
, и то, как вы только что это сформулировали
, заставило меня подумать, что если бы вы были  чтобы
запрограммировать компьютер с нуля,
это может быть абстрактный или виртуальный
компьютер, поэтому ему даже не нужно
иметь конкретное воплощение,
и в этой ситуации можно было бы
заняться сборкой
знаний, которые утверждают, что и сборкой
этих деклараций.  Активные
утверждения и логические процессы превращаются во
что-то более динамичное или
взаимодействующее с окружающей средой, однако
этот процесс, подобный полному проектированию стека
с логикой и силиконом в основе
, сильно отличается от того, как мы пришли сюда,
и поэтому он может быть, но это
дополняется,
хм, хорошо  вы дали небольшое представление
о том, что было до, во время и
после рецензирования, поэтому мне было просто
любопытно, что
изменилось во время и после статьи, например,
за последние месяцы или годы или
сколько бы времени это ни было, как вы развивались в этом,
а затем что  считаете ли вы важными
следующие шаги, независимо от того, предназначены ли они для вас или
просто в целом,
ищем ли мы измерение мозга, ищем ли мы
видеокамеру в лесу, ищем ли мы
концептуальный прогресс, что
будет двигаться вперед?  ваши
разработки
, это отличный вопрос, я думаю,
я не полностью удовлетворен тем,
как я буду использовать иностранный уровень, я не
знаю, будет ли это
выполняться  я, честно говоря, не знаю
, могли бы вы в принципе провести это в
других эмпирических терминах, но
я не говорю, что, ну
, я бы сегодня написал это немного по-
другому, не то чтобы это не
то, что я не согласен с  статья
изначально, но я
думаю, что есть некоторые моменты, которые я
хотел бы переформулировать, но они не
разрешают, э-э, либо я думаю, что у него была новая
статья,
но, возможно, в будущем, но это
то,
что вопросы, такие как миф,
дали, что  все еще философский
вопрос
и концептуальный вопрос, они все еще беспокоят
меня, но мне еще
предстоит найти возможность более тщательно развить эти
идеи, и общий
взгляд, который я изложил там, я думаю, я думаю, что
он все еще остается в
силе, но
я бы хотел, чтобы я  все еще я жду
этого шанса, чтобы развить его дальше и
посмотреть, как далеко я могу зайти, но я еще не знаю,
я должен признать, что я не знаю,
каковы будущие разработки этой идеи,
но я работаю  по нескольким
изолированным
вопросам  С этим подходом в
течение последних нескольких лет я работал
с понятием информации и научного
понимания и информации для
экологических и активистов
объединения, а недавно я работаю
совсем недавно с несколькими колледжами над
виртуальной реальностью и распознаванием восприятия,
так что
это  это то, как мне нравится проводить свои
исследования, чтобы найти
интересные вопросы и посмотреть, как я могу
с ними справиться, но не обязательно
оказаться привязанным к
одной линии рассуждений таким образом, так
что это то, что произошло в то время, когда я
работал с  рациональность, если бы я думал,
что это очень крутая тема, и я все еще
думаю, что это так, но у меня не было времени
вернуться и переформулировать то, что я хотел
, но, может быть, может быть, когда-нибудь в
ближайшем будущем, я не знаю, но больше
самая последняя вещь, над которой я работал
, не связана с клеточной
рациональностью, но я думаю, что некоторые продукты
могут быть неправильными, например,
виртуальная реальность, и
как визуальная реальность на самом деле
сравнивается с ком  бинация,
потому что явно чего-то не хватает
в настойчивости и визуальной
среде,
ну, конечно, если я кто-то,
например, если я нахожусь в визуальной
среде, где я нахожусь под
угрозой, я могу чувствовать что-то похожее на
страх, но  Я на самом деле не боюсь за свою
жизнь
и представляю, что человек в
виртуальной реальности, так разумно ли
убегать
от угрозы, виртуальной угрозы и т. д. и т. д.
вот это то, над
чем я работаю  и, может быть, это
обеспечивает точку возврата к
этой идее радикальной и активной
рациональности, и на самом деле статья
только что была принята, так что, как я уже
говорил вам, я был так занят в последние несколько
дней, потому что мы исправляли доказательства
моего  коллеги, и я никогда не образно
выражался, и я тоже был
с плотным графиком,
чтобы представить исправленную версию
статьи за последние несколько недель, а затем я
получил корректуру, и,
о,
ну, может быть, в будущем я смогу
вернуться к ИСС
я бы хотел, но я не знаю, если я
не знаю, я действительно не могу предвидеть
развитие этого, но в целом я
все еще согласен со своей первоначальной идеей, но
я сформулирую ее немного по-другому  немного
о том, что касается VR, я уверен, что там можно
еще многое сказать, но это напомнило
мне только название: виртуальная реальность, это
виртуализация, и так же, как
когнитивное планирование действий
позволяет нам принимать
политики, которые не делает наше тело.  t брать
хотя бы для того, чтобы оценить их и сделать выбор
против них, но мы можем пойти на
полет фантазии, мысленно провести причудливый процесс выбора политики,
но тогда наша морфология чем-то похожа на
нашу линию жизни, вы знаете, если вы действительно
упадете с уступа, тогда это  будет больно,
а затем в виртуальной реальности
вы воплотитесь в
перцептивном опыте, это
буквально виртуализация
критических ситуаций выживания, поэтому вы
можете видеть себя находящимся на уступе,
но вы находитесь на ровном полу,
а затем в этой ситуации
если вы своего рода
когнитивный наблюдатель за пределами
видеоигры, вы могли бы сказать, что
для меня рационально просто упасть, чтобы посмотреть,
что происходит,
так что это похоже на то, что
в пространстве есть слой рациональности, да,
как хороший ход  в игре,
хм, и поэтому это как бы стирает грань
между
[музыкой]
, она стирает
критичность тела и хм,
я уверен, что вы думали об этом гораздо
больше, так как это играет в нашу
виртуальную реальность
с  то, как мы думаем, используем
и проектируем эти системы,
это те
вопросы, которые побудили нас написать
статью, и NADA дал им, и я был в
том, что в технической литературе вы видите,
что многие исследователи, работающие
с  э-э, относитесь к визуальному восприятию как к иллюстрации,
своего рода иллюзии, но нас
это немного беспокоило, потому что, с
другой стороны, это работает только в виртуальной реальности, потому
что мы воплотили устройства, устройства, которые они
работают для нас, у вас есть контроллеры, у вас
есть голова  набор,
и кажется таким странным говорить, что
пользователь находится в своего рода
иллюзии,
а с другой стороны, кажется, что на
самом деле это не познание, потому что, как вы
сказали, нет
биологического отношения к этим когнитивным
Например, состояния, если я вижу
яблоко в виртуальной реальности, оно не дает
питания, но это имеет смысл в
игре, но другое, ну,
хорошо, я получил яблоко в
реальной среде, оно дает
питание.  это то, что я могу есть,
но не в виртуальной реальности, на что я могу притворяться, поэтому мы
придумали эту концепцию аллюзии на
его план,
э-э, это как если бы мы
столкнулись с настоящим животным, но это также включает в себя
эту волю к игре, эту идею о том,
что мы не
нас вводят в заблуждение, потому что мы надеваем
оборудование, мы знаем, что мы в игре,
и я думаю, что это сейчас горячая тема,
потому что есть метафоры, и я очень
скептически отношусь ко всему,
что может люди очень оптимистичны, но
относительно возможностей метави  rse,
и некоторые авторы действительно думают, что мы
могли бы быть в симуляции,
строго говоря, но я имею в виду, что лучшая
технология, которую показывают нам современные технологии
, заключается в том, что она очень ограничена, и вы можете
притворяться, что находитесь в определенной среде,
и так далее, и вот что я думаю.  могут
предложить новые новые способы
осмысления рациональности
в этой визуальной среде, например,
русские делают что-то, что подсказала
среда, чтобы спрыгнуть с уступа и посмотреть,
что происходит, а с другой стороны,
поведенческие аспекты этого иногда
люди на самом деле чувствуют.  страх и люди
выходят на улицу из-за фобий с виртуальной
реальностью,
и
это много, там много
интересных вопросов, которые,
может быть, я имею в виду для будущих исследований, которые мы можем
да вернуться к этому, это заставило меня задуматься о
том, как Apple в реальной жизни это  могут быть
калории для вас, но также это могут быть
калории для мухи, которую можно было бы бросить,
вы могли бы использовать ее как молоток, вы могли
бы правильно ее раскрасить, поэтому
экология и генеративность  процесс, как
мы бы сказали, активный вывод
всегда выходит за пределы
любых возможностей, которые были запрограммированы
для данного объекта, а затем,
хм, текущий дискурс о виртуальной реальности в
значительной степени сосредоточен на гарнитурах,
просто говоря совершенно анекдотично,
не в моей экспертной области,
хм, кажется  немного интересно,
это как если бы обсуждение мобильного телефона
было сосредоточено только на
прямоугольниках определенного размера,
что делает это не виртуальной реальностью, это
как смотреть в окно, и
есть еще один парень, с которым можно поговорить, поэтому
он не прикреплен к моей голове, это не
у некоторых технологий есть некоторые возможности отслеживания движения,
которые есть у некоторых технологий
, но
это нишевая модификация в личном пространстве Перри,
и мы можем передавать
сигналы и возможности друг другу,
поэтому имея виртуальную структуру или действительно просто
структуру рациональности и
познания циклов действий,
которые
не ограничиваются только одной конкретной
реализацией или типом оборудования и могут
охватывать весь диапазон от общего числа офлайн-
пользователей в поле
до  кто-то, кто очень хорошо знаком
с Матрице,
кажется довольно важным, в противном случае новые
технологии, даже небольшие варианты и
обновления программного обеспечения, будут продолжать просто
бесконечно удивлять и сбивать с толку,
да, я думаю, это трудно
определить границы,
я имею в виду, что мы здесь, э-э, в обмене,
который  Я думаю, что это может увеличиться, но
классифицировать его как форму виртуальной реальности,
конечно, я вижу, как вы разрушаете свой
разум, но
я имею в виду, что большинство, я думаю, работает, они в
настоящее время они считают это документом,
говоря, что у него должна быть гарнитура  а
иногда и контроллер, но в остальном
это звучит как виртуальная реальность, но
да, трудно что-либо определить
, это не свалка и
прямолинейность, это одна из вещей,
потому что, если говорить о коммерции,
конечно, виртуальная реальность означает гарнитуры
и другие атрибуты, но, но
телефон, просто разговаривающий по телефону, или
телеграф в то время был
бы на этом интерфейсе с той сенсорной
модальностью и с теми аффордансами, которые
он  виртуализация,
да, к которой у нас сегодня есть доступ, просто из
другой главы,
да, я так думаю, да, часть нашей статьи
состояла в том, чтобы утверждать, что в некотором смысле воплощение
технологических устройств
явно необходимо, не это не ново, это
признак того, чтобы быть человеком,
это  воплощение технологических устройств,
которые сделали нас теми, кто мы есть с самого
начала, с использованием аналитических технологий и
того факта, что мы можем так умело воплотить их
в устройство, даже если оно
запрограммировано, например, в
виртуальной реальности, чтобы иметь что-то
существо, которым вы управляете, богаче  новая
морфология другая морфология,
например, даже если это так, это
происходит так умело, потому что мы
можем воплотить устройство, некоторые
эксперименты показали, что вы можете сопоставить,
например, поворот вашего запястья с
третьей рукой,
из которой исходит индивидуальная реальность.
что из вашей груди люди могут
научиться контролировать эту третью руку,
которая не соответствует нашей фактической морфологии,
но может быть сделана таковой с помощью Поворота.  на
запястье, так
что это то, что мы обсудим в
нашей статье, что хорошо, вы можете,
вы можете сделать это только потому, что вы
воплощаете устройство, вы можете видеть, что это иллюзия,
это на самом деле
часть того, что я являюсь человеком, для
вышивания технологических устройств, поэтому
я  Я имею в виду, я знаю, что это
стирает различие между виртуальными
и не виртуальными наушниками. Я думаю, что это один из
способов справиться с этим
крутым.
хотел бы поблагодарить вас за
возможность обсудить этот документ, это было
очень приятно для меня, мне это очень понравилось,
и это очень приятная и
удобная среда для обсуждения этих
вопросов и размышлений, спасибо еще раз
спасибо, да, отличная дискуссия и
важные темы и  мы будем рады
поговорить с вами снова в любое время
хорошо спасибо прощай спасибо